he's the Kentucky basketball coach he's
John Calipari good to have him back on
the program coach good morning how are
you I'm going good now you notice I was
on time and when you did let everybody
know I was probably about 12 minutes
late yeah and by the way your listeners
haven't listened to that podcast there
was so much stuff I learned about you
and you know what after listening to it
I even dislike you more I mean it it was
really good stuff buddy way go ahead I
had a lot of fun want to take up then go
ahead I did can I have permission to
start a rumor that you'll be the next
head coach of the New Orleans pelicans I
just you know guys don't normally ask
permission to start a rumor I was just
asking permission if I could start the
rumor what socks do you have on do you
have them inside out I know I have them
I have them regular okay I only only do
that one time I only had my socks inside
out that one time because I warm you
know right side out the the previous day
yeah and your and your underwear too
right you did that once
Yeah right so just give me a vague
non-denial denial that you're yeah just
so I can run with some on it's a slow
day coach come on I know you know I was
at the all-star game last night because
my son said are we going to the all-star
game players we had a day off I did my
tape work we left later in the day we
get down there and and then all the
stuff was swirling I didn't get to talk
to DeMarcus and and if you know I don't
know if any pro athletes listen to your
show I doubt it but if they do they know
that being traded is it do you just like
you agree it's the worst and even if it
is a trade that is a good thing for both
parties and for the players being traded
knocks these guys for a loop
so DeMarcus
loved Sacramento he felt it was his home
he loved the fans they just weren't
winning and maybe they didn't have
enough but I'm telling you both he and
Anthony they're about winning Anthony
Davis when I recruited him just said all
I want to do is win don't you don't even
need to tell me where I'm gonna play
I'll play wherever you want me to the
kid ended up taking the fourth most
shots on my team that year and he just
scored 52 in an all-star game that's how
much he's unselfish and how stupid I am
the market they say what they want he
was unselfish for us here he played with
John Wallen Patrick Patterson and Eric
Bledsoe he shared he goes to USA
basketball he shared if you talk to Mike
sous-chefs key he'll tell you he didn't
have any issues with him and he brought
him off the bench now obviously he and
Anthony are gonna have to figure it out
together and it's going to take time
it's you know if anybody thinks okay now
they're just starting to win you need
guards you needed schemes that you feel
comfortable with that you're gonna learn
just like when Cleveland just started
with LeBron it took time it took took
them a couple months before they really
start clicking how would you use those
two in New Orleans you know I would say
with Alvin Gentry the one thing that
when you look at him he is a very very
bright offensive coach you know out of
the mold of the you know Golden State
and all that I think he'll figure it out
you got one that's a little more
physical you got one Anthony could play
the three you know you don't have to be
the four you could play with a small
five and have DeMarcus play for any
issues DeMarcus would have defensively
well Anthony Davis is behind you leading
the league in blocks so this could be
crazy and in its they just kind of
figure it out together and it's just not
gonna happen in a week it just doesn't
but I'll tell you what there are two
players that want to win that like each
other
that Anthony is Anthony just wants a win
when they lost the playoff game I think
it was a year ago or you know
the first round game the year before we
couldn't find him for a week I mean the
kid was crushed you know he sees himself
in an organization that starts vying for
Championships and you know what it
starts with having talented players yeah
I think people think this is gonna be
immediate and I it's not gonna happen
overnight as you said yeah I want to
know who your guards are and these guys
find finding their spacing there and and
you know right can we look at something
where you got a 23 year old and 25 year
old and say we got a bright future you
do Anthony Davis says he wants to stay
in New Orleans and if boogie can find
that he likes the atmosphere there and
the direction of the team then all right
maybe you got something here but until
you show me who the guards are I don't I
can't handicap that team right and and
they'll figure it out
I mean I'm telling you they they had to
have a plan if we get this done now
there's gonna be pressure on us to win
and the only way we can achieve that is
if we have good guard play and they come
on these guys are professionals I mean
tell them guys they know what you're
doing and and you know I think again you
know you look at that situation it would
be neat for New Orleans to have a team
that's doing that I mean let you know I
won I like the city I think you know I
love going down there and you know all
that stuff but that is a place with that
storm that came through and wrecked the
place and it was almost done to see some
sort of rebirth and have it be through
the NBA you know when you're talking
about the NBA the greatest thing about
the all-star game last night they put
all the flags up of all the players from
the world that were in the game I was
incredible you sit there and you're like
oh my gosh you you talk about a melting
pot you talk about you know true
[Music]
franchising and in an organization like
the NBA that's about inclusion come on I
mean that was neat last night he's a
John Calipari Kentucky head coach
joining us who's the player in the
all-star game who you tried to recruit
you didn't get him
well I'm gonna tell you who I saw don't
tell anybody
for the first time because I'm not
watching much MBA other than my own
players the Greek Greek yeah oh my god
yeah I mean this guy's ridiculous I mean
I watched him ago and he was challenged
by Anthony now he wanted to say look and
he's big long he plays like a guard did
you know about him big dope did you know
about I know I went but David Babcock
worked for me when I was the New Jersey
Nets what happened to me when I was in
that coach it didn't go well yeah I got
fired he was he was my player personnel
director and David told me I said why
would you take the guy from Greece are
you kidding me he goes wait till you see
this guy and so I kept hearing about him
and I you know Milwaukee you don't get
to see him on TV and then I watched last
night I looked at my son and I said Brad
did you know this guy was this good I
mean literally he's the next wave unless
I just was excited about playing I don't
know I have to watch him more but I mean
the length and skill and David tells me
he's one of its good a player better
person which means that he'll be in
Milwaukee his whole career and if they
get some other guys they need guards
they need guards yep
and he they tell me they play him at
point guard at times what dude 7-foot
tall
when's the last time you had an employer
I wish I would have found him if I would
have found I would have had a seven foot
point guard drove everybody crazy you
think they're mad now all day when's the
last time you had a former players sake
coach one should come coach our team no
no after having them here and and you
watched I coach these guys yeah the only
coach of a murder yeah there they didn't
get tired of yeah yeah yeah but believe
me it's like seven years they say no and
then and then what's on them here and
then how they have to sacrifice
I mean I've held every player I've
coached back if you ask them
from Anthony to Michael to Terrence you
could go to John to DeMarcus you know
that big play in games they start
shooting threes and look over at me like
yeah you didn't let me shoot these Karl
towns I went to one game the first four
shots Karl took four threes cuz I won't
let him shoot three here he looks at me
like that
this is what you had you didn't use but
you know what I'd rather be in a
situation I meant to be a help to be a
mentor to be whatever they need me to be
and if they don't need me and we text
everything up once in a while that's
fine - I'm not you know was you know
last night again my son said are we
going to the all-star game Sunday we
have an off day it went like that like
we and I you know I asked a master
George after we should have gotten beat
at Georgia Georgia played great I said
do you really want to go that game he
said yes so we went down and watched and
got to see DeMarcus and Anthony and John
and and the other guys you know I got to
see AI was there I got to you know say
hello to him I hadn't seen him since the
Hall of Fame induction stuff but but you
you bring up Georgia and and you beat
Georgia and then you got riled up after
the game and you stood up for other
coaches what are you talking about
I got riled up I don't get rattled up
you got my mind but you got excited
agitated well here's my point how are we
firing coaches at midseason it's
basically tell me what it does your your
break you know you're not a bright guy
but you're a guy tell me what it does
what do you do by firing a guy midseason
unless you're saying we're going to
announce that the job is open early and
or you give an assistant coach a chance
to get some run as a head coach but I
I'm with you I don't like it I don't I
don't like when you fire a coach so let
me let me go farther the reason that
situation is there the pressure right
now is all on the ad to do something so
by doing it he takes the heat off
himself or she instead of just saying
look we'll figure this out when it's
over
and if the coach goes on a heck of a run
and they go in the NCAA tournament they
get to a sweet 16 or busted think about
Syracuse last year how bad they were
do you know how bad they were early and
they were in the Final Four
what were you gonna fire the guy at
midseason well you could say well he
wasn't coaching stop you know the same
thing with Duke this year Duke struck we
struggled in the middle so what I said
after the game is I'm having a clause
put in my contract you can fire me at
midseason but there's gonna be a
monetary you gonna have to pay me more
money than you even owe me like fire me
in the season but because again to
discourage that and I told all coaches
you should all do it every coach should
do it yeah but you're not getting fired
you're not getting fired me I'm fired
already I already got I know what it
feels like not it can you know what you
ready I got fired in the middle of us
well I wasn't a season it was a lockout
I don't even know what you call it but I
was in the middle yeah but you ain't
you're gone I was do you think Kentucky
will fire you
one day if I try to stay too long yeah
not post that I can promise won't happen
not possible not possible no yeah I
agree
so they're never gonna by not I know you
know I won't because one I don't want to
die in the seat and two we'll know you
and I we will talk off the record like
you had a heck of a run man you know
what I'm saying you had a heck of a run
here's what's happened right now and why
it looks the way it does we've gotten on
a roll of being able to get the best and
the brightest and great kids who are
good people who want to do this together
and win and I'm in a position that it
goes beyond just basketball
we're helping families we're creating
hope and I'm having a ball with it now I
want to win every game we play you ever
watch me coach don't act like I don't
want to win don't stop well you don't
want to win championships no I want to
lose championship see you out of your
mind yes I do but not at the expense of
the kids I'm not going to sit a kid down
and I'm not going to do that I'm gonna
do everything I can to help
and if it doesn't work at some point
it'll be his decision why are you
stepping back
so we're it's unique here right now but
this may change there may be a
circumstance that changes this where I
don't feel the same which is we're
creating hope this is more than just
basketball this is more about families
than it is about basketball
yeah we'll teach him we had a meeting
this morning showing tape we're teaching
basketball we're trying to get it right
but it's bigger than that here that's
why I can sustain this for a while but
to say I'm going to do this 20 years
you'll see me and look at me and say I
don't think the guy came here oh yeah
your hair sticking up in the back yeah
you know I'm not gonna go to that I
don't need to you know it's that's not
what moves me it's not the walking in
arena and day that doesn't move me you
know what moves me now if my age is
[Music]
we're creating hope for people and kids
now I'm making them responsible for
themselves you should have heard the
meeting this morning they are
responsible for themselves we're here to
help but you're responsible for you I'm
not responsible for you your performance
own it there are they're 22 and 5
they're at Missouri coming up tomorrow
night and as your son gotten any more
tattoos no because of you but he's
wearing socks inside out because he saw
that show and but he knows the tattoos
are out because you just absolutely
crushed the blanket he's you know he's
right now he walks around with his head
down I hope they feel good but that's I
yeah III hope something good happens to
your son in life there coach have you
people listened to that podcast if they
want to really if they want to know I'm
going to tell you truthfully I've never
you one I always kind of like I don't
know what have any idea why but you were
so open in that thing and there was so
much stuff I learned about you that I
did not know
and you know what you're you're a
battler you care about people and that's
why you've had this success you walked
away from you walked away from the gravy
train yeah and did your own thing I mean
it's and I okay it's why I like going on
I I know I can bust you and you're not
gonna cry like a big baby
you know it's you bust me and I want to
smack you in the mouth but I don't leave
you alone it's all good that's why you
don't like going on Mike and Mike
because they're big babies is what you
told me that's what I heard oh you're
gonna say something different now that
we're on the radio okay all right tough
guy don't screw it up at Missouri thanks
brother that's John Calipari Continental
Tire Coaches Corner
proud to be the exclusive tire the Dan
Patrick show no matter where you drive
or what you drive Continental designs
tires for what you do for more
information visit Continental Tire kaam
Continental Tire for what you do the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
[Music]